[Music]
and it works and get up at this point
bridle on it this part is well I'm going
to die immediately oh no it just
happened so fast you know it's this game
suffers their shots riding on them
nothing else I Bruce I think you've got
you got it you've got it this is where I
says where I have real real trouble yeah
he's cool those guys are so hard Bruce
that was an excellent attempt so hard
[Music]
ma robot I was kind of lower to beat it
on for us I'm trying I'm trying okay you
got three people you can eat lined up
[Laughter]
you did good what's next to me boom
that's it let's do this here we go got
this one no problem no problem he's
already good yeah that's shotgun I would
like to eat you doing great okay nice
all right next to like that
yeah you're doing great Ilana oh you got
it you're good I think you're on the
other side of this all right yes all
right
use the strap eat everyone yeah and
generally manhandling that Kristen hell
yeah it's Christopher
but there's some more about there then
do 2016 you got orbs of origin energy
and we all know what that means yeah of
course it came from us was that no
crystals that could be something else
the night sentinels bruise on our dinner
get in that port go in mom rope you got
the memories where I know where is he
there it is that's the play belt give me
that ass [ __ ] suck it ass take that you
do that Wow hit the shot oh [ __ ] come on
[Music]
where where am i oh you're on electric
floral on your electric floor you're
right we're on let the record show I
told you in advance this room is [ __ ]
garbage really oh oh you know there were
yeah mostly the like the fights that
have Marauders in them did I do it I
think I did it yes
yeah but I recall I thought he was Vega
is the AI that controlled the UAC a
facility on Mars I know I know but I
know you don't have enough men to betray
you though no oh you saved Vega
that was the only like human thing
doomsayer did in 2016 we Messire smashed
everything in front of him but when he
had the opportunity to destroy Vega he
chose to back them up and stand light
yeah why what did he what a dupe site
before he killed demons well that's a
great question and there are some hints
about that and do maternal you should
play it
hi I have I want to check it out oh you
guys have you guys been checking those
make sure that the donations didn't pop
up from a tree yeah this is that these
are the jump scares Ilana I know every
time I panic yeah every me to every
single though every time I wish I could
see what my heart rate does when the
tentacles pop up not a girl's best
friend okay
or is it yep nice one shot there's one
thing I love there's no love about it
well no well sort of diamond or oh look
at that this is all pretty though yeah
it's so cool all right this is the one
yeah this is the one I'm gonna wait for
this [ __ ] to pop right here it's
not a way to like convert of court and
you fourteen-year-old scribbles into 4k
write it this game is also you've got
the sniper rifle do you want to snipe
off that cater right that I do that is
correct you can do it from here anyway
there it is easy enough about five bucks
you know what flame belching while
waiting for Cacodemons
yeah yeah you got it you got honey
you're good we're back we're back
oh the writer on the phone yeah no
you're not gonna die don't say that you
ain't gonna die
there it is right now it's still up you
ain't gon knock
there we go man you got it easy easy
it was a wreck no bombs sheva noon is
Iraq no Vereen real fast
woof that's a big whoop please die he's
not gonna die you guys have to [ __ ] you
a lot all right there's a coding deal up
there may have been but I don't know you
got him you gotta move oh I pressed the
button oh my gosh what happened I don't
know did I just get bitch-slapped oh oh
boy yeah what's happening
Oh No what's me ran right in front of it
what's hip you find you find you find
the [ __ ] it even shows up right about
now there we go right for it
yeah so that is that quad it's called
rampage the a squad okay
my favorite is the one that makes you
see
oh yeah boy that's a big boy they're
like the [ __ ] awesome yeah it is oh
nice you got the trip I didn't get oh oh
you're right you did not get a turtle oh
okay you'll be all right
[Music]
what look
no I woke now that was messy actually I
think we're on nightmare we are now yeah
we absolutely are now white rabbit
object thank you for donating wait we're
wheelman
where we uh nightmare no no well I died
faster than I would have thought it just
used to fly alone all night nice
pressure on him oh gee that's the way I
think I already know it's not know we're
[ __ ]
come on we're on nightmare deferred
charity have some faith have some faith
you got this here's the thing pick up
that natal God because God kills demons
he does God kills demons have some faith
God rips and tears bro there are many
times every time the camera changes I
think I think we're doing great a lot
great to help along you got that 32 you
got it you did you did that was not your
fault
that's some bull shot your father has
happened to me multiple times not your
fault there's like some geometry that
hooks you up well it was there there
what the [ __ ]
what happened Lawrence is gonna beat it
right now [ __ ] got this do you know
who [ __ ] got this okay go
yes oh yeah and you'll find no big deal
that's that way those are controls that
was the controls I really want to not be
in LA we got 60 L not 50 it's still not
good but it doesn't count as low health
it does go up ultra ultra violence yeah
III think they might scale it by the oh
you're 30 you'll keep dying to boss
there we go yeah you got him okay
Oh bad news guys bad news look at that
somebody donated $500 to Alana's chat we
got a hot guy got 500 oh you better turn
on hey you know what happens right now
what the hamburger i'ma just go home let
me just go back to base for a bit there
is
Longview got put on nightmare yeah yeah
the Porchester doomed or ammonia that's
one he chose to donate which by the way
thank you what donating money to uh
Meals on Wheels which will help both the
elderly and the disabled but also [ __ ]
[Music]